speaking of things that cost a lot but
are super exciting
uh page two
crap no we're we'll wrap it up
calm down this is there's more than page
two what do you think this is
this is uh jesus
well louis de broyley's thesis was three
pages long and he won the nobel prize
for the wave particle duality
so you know size
matters in different dimensions in life
i think the the lessons i've learned
about life is the shorter the paper or
the shorter the thesis
uh actually the shorter the paper some
of the greatest papers ever written are
sure like i feel like uh
some of the best ideas in this world
not to sound like a contradiction of
feynman a contradiction on top of a
contradiction but it could be written on
a napkin honestly
um it's just kind of it tells you
something about ideas
you